hello everyone and welcome to another
video now last month we took a look at
the new Intel Arc b580 and today we're
taking a look at its baby brother the
b570 this is a 10 GB graphics card so a
little bit about the card I have the
sparkle Guardian OC Edition I bought the
sparkle b580 really impressed with it
that was a three fan design really quiet
even underload and I can say the same
for the b570 unfortunately we don't get
the little anti-ag bracket that came
with the B5 f8 we have the same 8 Pin
connectivity here and the little uh
connection protection things you know
the things that plug into the HDMI uh
display port and all that came in this
separate little bag which was a nice
touch they're not sure why they weren't
plugged in to the connectors but never
mind let's get into it the b570 then
this one seems to be clocked at a Max of
2750 MHz as opposed to the b580
2850 I'm going to be talking through
each game today talking about the
performance discussing what I feel about
the performance itself where I think
some improvements could be made and just
generally discussing my initial
impressions of this well what is uh to
be considered I guess a modern budget
card we'll start off then with cyberpunk
2077 you can see the footage on screen
already we have 84 FPS here at the high
settings looks good at high we have the
high crowd density as well I'm actually
using the b570 with an i s 712 700f my
personal CPU these days I think it
actually works pretty well of course we
have to be aware of the CPU overhead
situation and that is basically that
this card will perform not as well as it
should with less expensive processors I
read an article about it um the 5600
ryzen for example will give worse
results than using a higher end ryzen
and I think the same can be said for
Intel CPU not just the standard what
you'd expect lower performance because a
lower CP but there's definitely uh some
sort of utilization issue going on as
well with the i71 12700 this is a chip I
paid £50 for secondhand I think it's
actually a decent choice and it seems to
be working okay with The Arc but it
should give you some idea of how it
works with a CPU that's not top end of
the spectrum and perhaps a better
example of what you may end up pairing a
card like this with I'm not quite sure
about that power consumption reading
it's recording less than 100 wats a lot
of the time which seems a little
inaccurate to me but performance-wise
the figures seem pretty spoton I'll have
some comparisons towards the end of the
video as well to the b58 in a few
demanding examples but before then let's
move on to the borders Gate 3 gameplay
here 1080p High settings once again with
TAA taking a walk around the lower City
here for2 frames per second on average
the 1% low recorded at 72 and the. 1%
figure was 44 so all in all a fairly
consistent experience from The Arc card
once again our GBU seems to be fully
utilized here running at 2750 MHz and
running at less than 60° I have to say
this is really quiet in my system today
I'll probably do a 1440p benchmark video
at some point as well running through a
few titles at higher resolution maybe
even pushing it to 4K there are a few
things I'd like to test with the b570
much as I did with the b580 as well for
the black myth woong Benchmark we have
1080p low XC SS was enabled but the
resolution scaling was set to 100% so
we're not upscaling from a lower res
here this is full fat 1080p as it were
for 72 frames per second seems to be
running a little better than when I
previously tested this with the
b580
6257 that's the latest driver at the
time of this video coming in at about
1.4 GB so big down loads the latest
driver is the one I'm using as I always
do for these test uh benchmarks and
things may of course be different if
you're watching this at a later time
that said one game I am still having
problems with is Counter Strike 2 here
at 1080p high with anti sing off because
it defaults to msaa by default and of
course that's a bit of a a frame rate
hog as it were we're seeing 232 frames
per second now this sounds absolutely
fine and looks fine on paper but the 1%
low of 111 and the. 1% low of 15 do
indicate a few issues and that is with
consistency every so often and I'm not
sure if you can pick it up on screen
there's a little sort of dip in the
frame times a little I guess you could
call Micro stutter it threw me off a bit
during gaml this is a problem that I saw
with the b580 as well I remember Counter
Strike go used to perform horribly on
Arc cards at first when the a750 first
came out so performance has much
improved to be fair it's significantly
better than it was on Art cards with
this new uh game CS2 but I think there
is still a little work to be done and we
can see that in terms of GPU utilization
it's a bit all over the place as well
sort of going between 50 and 100% that
could just be impairing with this
processor but I seem to recall this
happening with the I9 that I tested with
the b580 previously as well now Elder
ring is more of a consistency test than
anything because this is capped at 60
FPS by default and I tend to leave this
cap on of course it hits 60 on average
with the highest settings at 1080P and
in terms of consistency it seems to run
really well on the arc card 56 FPS as
that 1% low and 44 as that 0.1% low so
no issues to report here and with these
settings I think the game still looks
pretty good I've added a new game to The
Benchmark roster Marvel Rivals having
some fun playing this one actually High
settings with the high preset the only
thing I changed was the global
illumination which defaulted to lumen
and I turn Lumen off because it's a bit
of an FPS hog I don't think the gain in
visual quality is worth the FPS
sacrifice because visually doesn't seem
to look that much different and I don't
feel it's that important for an online
competitive game like this nonetheless
1080p with high we saw 87 frames per
second a 1% low of 52 and a 0.1% low of
33 for the Witcher 3 ultra settings here
this is the nextg version of the game of
course taau was also enabled for 135
frames per second in around the city
here we saw a 1% low of 88 and a0 1% low
of 70 so again no real issues with this
game I think this may have been one that
I had problems with initially with Arc
cards years ago but here it seems to be
running absolutely fine no complaints
for me with this
one next up we have the classic Grand
Theft Auto 5 now of course this has had
a few issues with Arc cards in the past
but it only seems to be getting better
with time 1080p the highest settings and
the ADV settings also set to maximum
here along with FXAA returned 109 frames
per second the percentile lows were
actually pretty decent as well despite
seeing the GPU usage all over the place
the performance overall was fairly good
now I did turn msaa off because that
absolutely destroys our frame rate I'd
expect GTA 5 to run well though because
it's fairly old or so you may think but
as I mentioned there have been notable
problems with Arc gpus in the past and I
think now it's certainly running a lot
smoother than it has been
previously I've thrown The Last of Us
Part One into the Benchmark roster as
well because this can be quite demanding
at Native resolution and I was curious
to see how it ran on an arc GPU it's
also quite the vram hog at 1080p medium
you can see the game is uh utilizing at
least 9 gigs or 9 gigs plus is being
assigned to the game we're actually
using about 6.9 so encroaching on um 7
gigs here if I was using an 8 gig card
I'd be a little bit nervous perhaps I
think medium settings at Native is a
nice place to be with the ark b570 and
as you can see from the performance
metrics the card is being fully utilized
as well in pairing with the i7 99% as we
move on to stalker 2 I want to remind
you that rebar or resizable bar is of
course switched on that is basically a
must for Intel Arc cards I made a video
with the b580 at rebar on versus off
just to show you the performance and in
some cases the differences were huge it
was a bit of a mess with rebar off so
I'd recommend using an arc card with a
system that supports rebar most systems
built within the last half a decade or
so should support this feature but it's
worth double checking on your
motherboard manufacturer site whether or
not your system is going to support this
as it is a must for Arc cars in order to
get the best performance from them
anyway in terms of actual performance
for stalker 2 This is the the only game
I really needed to turn XC SS on for
especially at the settings I wanted to
use medium with X SS quality even at low
we couldn't maintain at least 60 frames
per second so I thought I'd use xss
quality here and picture quality looks
absolutely fine to be fair this is a
pretty demanding title of course now we
have Red Dead Redemption 2 and you may
remember that we had some issues with
this one namely in and around Valentine
whereby the performance would just drop
and we'd see about 30 frames per second
just disappear in an instance I'm not
quite sure what that was about GPU
utilization does drop still the clock
speed remains at 2750 and performance
does decrease a little bit but I think
it has certainly improved since we last
tested Red Dead 2 with an arc C seems to
be a bit smoother and consistent with
the b570 now and the
6257 drivers Call of Duty Black Ops 6 up
next 1080p B we're getting 83 FPS with
consistent percentile lows as well 59
and 45 the gam playay does look a little
more stuttery than it is my capture card
decided to play around at this point so
this was actually uh internal recording
from the Xbox game bar built into
Windows 10 so the gaml might look a bit
choppier than it actually is but it was
running and it felt really smooth I
thought I'd finalize with a little bit
of a ray tracing test of course these
new Intel art cards do support RT here
I'm using the RT Ultra preset with X SS
balanced you're going to need X SS or
another form of upscaling enabled
perhaps FSR if you want to enable ra
tracing and get at least 60 FPS with one
of these cards I was surprised however
at this result 69 FPS on average better
than I was expecting we can definitely
tell that upscaling is enabled but it's
still fairly sharp I wouldn't like to
drop any lower than balanced I'd say but
I don't think we need to here because
we're seeing plus 60 FPS and actually
the percenti were fairly consistent as
well 51 and 46 just look at the vram
utilization I think uh that can be
thanked for the smooth performance here
right so here we have a few games that
I've taken for comparison sake tested
the b570 and then the b580 Cyber Punk
here 84 FPS compared to 95 for the b580
borderers Skate 3 102 versus 111 for the
b580 the percenti lows are also improved
as well th so far uh The Last of Us 67
and 7 3 for the b570 and b580
respectively of course with a boost in
the percenti low as well and then The
Witcher 3 the b570 hit 135 and the b580
hit 149 so both of course are playable
but again the percental lows are
improved with the b580 now the current
price is I do think the b570 is worth it
if you want to save some money here in
the UK you're looking at 4050 difference
especially with the current markup on
the b580 cards it seems that both are in
stock at the moment price are a little
higher than what I'd want to see
especially if you take into
consideration the price of 40 60s as
well which of course is going to trade
blows with these cards it would be nice
to see the b570 drop a little lower 220
something like that and it would be nice
to see the b580 come down in price too I
think if there's like 30 quid $30
between the two you might as well just
go for the b580 if it's in stock the
extra vram is nice to have as well but
the b570 is still a nice choice if you
want to save a little bit more cash and
we do have to bear in mind the whole
overhead thing in terms of performance
whether or not we'll see fixes with
driver updates and how this will affect
certain titles but I wanted to use 12700
F because it's not a really high-end CPU
it's not a completely budget CPU either
somewhere in the middle and I always try
to give you an idea of what you can
expect if you're not using the highest
End Hardware out there I also had this
paired with 32 gigs of ddr4 3200 me
hurts memory as well so hopefully this
has been helpful but let me know your
thoughts down below I'll have a few more
b570 tests over the weekend hopefully
and hopefully you can join me for those
too but all that's left to say is thank
you for watching and I'll see you all
next time